president Donald Trump has threatened to
pull the plug on one of the most
important arms treaties of past 30 years
one side has not been adhering to it we
have but one side hasn't signed in 1987
between Russia and America the
intermediate-range nuclear forces treaty
otherwise known as the INF contributed
to the beginning of the end of the Cold
War for more than a decade Russia has
been cheating the terms of the deal but
what would the death of the nuclear pact
mean for world peace
in 1987 after years of negotiation the
superpowers agreed to meet
[Music]
today I for the United States and the
general secretary for the Soviet Union
have signed the first agreement ever to
eliminate an entire class of US and
Soviet nuclear weapons we have made
history mr. Reagan and mr. Gorbachev
agreed to destroy and never again
produce land-based missiles with a range
of 500 to 5500 miles are already
speculating as to who has won I reject
this approach it is a throwback to old
thinking at the time The Economist
reported that the world had crossed the
Rubicon of nuclear disarmament but
warned that the West should tread
carefully because Western public opinion
may be lulled into thinking that Russia
is no longer an adversary in the
Department of Defense we viewed
Gorbachev as someone we could do
business with he was looking to the
future and understood it could not be
based on confrontation with the West
Frank Miller spent 30 years working for
the US government on national security
and negotiated nuclear deals with the
Russians
this is what the INF treaty was all
about but thirty years after the
landmark treaty both sides blame the
other for breaking the agreement in 1987
we were looking to work together and
there was a spirit of cooperation there
is now a spirit of confrontation
emanating from Moscow Putin is using his
intelligence services and his cyber
services to try to disrupt events in the
West and today the Russians actually
believe that nuclear weapons are useful
weapons of war and certainly they use
them all the time as weapons of coercion
and intimidation continue over the past
decade Russia has been testing and
deploying missiles that break the deal
the Russians say that it is America
that's broken the treaty claiming NATO's
defense shield in Romania and Poland has
the capacity to fire intermediate-range
missiles into Russia relations between
the United States and Russia now are
poor and are getting worse we need to
make clear to mr. Putin that aggression
against the United States is not a
policy goal he can pursue both sides
have six months to negotiate before the
deal is disbanded but if the treaty
collapses the consequences could be
severe other countries who are not
signatories to the INF including China
India and Israel have been stockpiling
missiles the US and Russia may look to
catch-up sparking an arms race that
could jeopardize what is left of global
arms control most worryingly
the potential death of the INF has
called into question the New START
treaty a pact between Russia and America
that deals with long-range nuclear
missiles if this is not agreed there
would be no constraint on the nuclear
forces of America and Russia for the
first time in all